على الجيتار
[موسيقى]
مع و
مدلع اه متلوع وفي قلبه حكايات
بتولع
ده كانن عصفور
مدلع اه متلوع وفي قلبه حكايات
[موسيقى]
بتولع
هغني
ولازمني ادف وابعد حزني راح اغني
ولازمني ادفى وابعد حزني راح اغني
ولازمني ادفى وابعد حزني ده كاني عصفور
مدلع اه متلوع وفي قلبه حكايات
بتولع ور
[موسيقى]
ايه اني عصفور
مدلع اه متلوع وفي قلبه حكايات
بتولع ده كاني عصفور
[موسيقى]
بتولع
فوتوغرافيا
فوتوغرافيا بشوف الدنيا من
عدسه وبلطه بعين صافيه حاجات ياما ما
بنقولها والصوره لوحدها
كافيه بشوف الدنيا من
عدس وبلطه بعين
صافيه حاجات ياما ما
بنقولها وصوره لوحدها كافيه
فوتوغرافيا
فوتوغرافيا يا ليل يا ليل يا
ليل
بطلع صوره
للفقراء وهم بيعبروا
الشارع بهدمه مقطعه
ومناديل وضحكه من الزمن
حافيه بطلع صوره
للفقراء وهم بيعبروا
الشارع بهدمه مقطع
ومناديل وضحكه من الزمن حافا
فوتوغرافيا
[موسيقى]
فوتوغرافيا يا ليل يا ليل يا
ليل
[موسيقى]
في احطام بالرغم الا بتطلع
الكاميرا وفي احضام برغم البعد بتطلع في
الصور
دافيه في احضام برغم القرب بتطلع بارده في
[موسيقى]
الكاميرا وفي احضام برغم البعد بتطلع في
الصور
دافيه
فوتوغرافيا
فوتوغرافيا يا ليل يا ليل يا
[موسيقى]
ليل انا الشخص اللي
بيصور ومش
تلاقي صور
ليا فمن فضلك ما
[موسيقى]
تكبرني واخد لك صوره
بالعافيه واخد لك صوره
بالعافيه
فوتوغرافيا
[موسيقى]
فوتوغرافي
شكرا اسمير ع بطوس بالموس اطلع دكتور تلبس
اراجوز وتنط تفط تكفر اعوز وانقل ق لك مز
تقول له يا موز وان قال مش لاعب قوله ده
لوز ما احناش
ناقصين ع بطوس
[موسيقى]
بالموز كتاكيت كتاكيت راقص وتنطي
بط البطابيط لعب
وتخبيط بيقولوا ضحوي ولكنه عبيط بيقولوا ض
حويط ولكنه عبيط فاهم لاعب شغل التثبيط
تكريس معير عبدوس بالمس طلع دكتور تلبس
اراجوز وتنط تفط كفر اع لوس وان قاللك مز
تقول له يا مز وانقال مش لاعب قول له ده
لوس ما احناش
ناقصين ناقصين ايه ع بطوس
بالم
[موسيقى]
ه كركور فرفور عم بيدور وانا عايزه يغور
ولع له النور طفيله النور ادي الجمهور
دخان وبخور وديكور ملووح بيلف يدور وبطلنا
اهو شحرور امور واحنا المساكين طالعين
نازلين واحنا المساكين طالعين نازلين ومش
شايفين رايحين على
فين
والجان تحكيم ضرب لنا
البوز ع
بطوس بالمو
[موسيقى]
شكرا الساعه وقالت موقف بيحصلك كل يوم
وانا كنت متاخر على البت وانت رايح تقابل
صاحبتك والجو حر جدات في الساعه وقالت
النيا زحمه فيش مواصلات وانا كنت متاخر
بينا نشوف اللي
هيحصل بصيت في الساعه وقالت
ت وانا كنت متاخر على
البت بصيت في الساعه وقالت
شت وانا كنت متاخر على
البت انا قلت اتكلم
واطمن ولا في راصيد ولا باقه
[موسيقى]
نت
وركبت التاكسي لابو عداد يا سيدي بس
السواق كان راجل
غديت وفجاه الزحمه من غير
معاد 70 جنيه اه يا ابن
الين وركبت التاكسي لابو
عداد بس السواق كان راجل
غدي وفجاه الزحمه من غير
عاد 70 جنيه اه يا ابن
الدي ولان الوقت باظ فركبت الميكرو باظ
ولان الوقت باظ فركبت الميكرو باظ عربيه
محتاجه
البنزين والاجره زادت للض عفين
[موسيقى]
و
oh وسكت العده وقلت
الو لقيت واحده بتقول لي
تفو ومسكت العده وقلت
تفو بقى نركن ساعتين على
الحيط طب انا مشاه وراجعه
البيت بصيت في الساعه وقالت
ش وانا كنت متاخر على
البيت بصت في الساعه وقالت
شد وانا كنت متاخر على
البت انا قلت اتكلم
واطمن ولا في رصيد ولا باقه
نت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرا
[موسيقى]
الله
بك
[موسيقى]
استجيب
يا الله
[موسيقى]
الله بك
استجير ومن
يجير
[موسيقى]
فاجر
ضعيف
فجر
يحتمي
بحماك
[موسيقى]
اني
ضعيف اني
ضعيف
واستعين
على قوي
[موسيقى]
ذنبي
ومعصيتي
بض
قواه
اذنبت
يا
[موسيقى]
ربي وقادتني
ذنوبي فليرض النا
س عني او
يسخطوا
انا لما عود
السعه انا لمعد
[موسيقى]
اسعى لغير رضاك
يا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رب